he also admits that peace in a marriage
so he was talking at one point about you
know people wanting peace in a marriage
peace in their relationship they just
want to come home to a happy home and be
a peaceful place a warm inviting place
he said and he used the word really
about six times he said that peace in a
marriage is really really really really
really really hard to attain true peace
he calls it a high level goal the
Promised Land
so
I found it interesting that he was
admitting that there's all this [ __ ]
work that you have to do
to put all your assets at risk of losing
half of them because a prenup won't hold
up after about seven to ten years anyway
I mean they're only good for a few years
and if she stays working
to end up in the promised land of Peace
in a relationship when you can just have
peace by not inviting somebody into your
house and getting married and living
away the state gets to [ __ ] mess with
your life so
it's an interesting
comment but I thought I would you know I
thought I would frame it from that angle
just to sort of offer a little bit of
Insight in it
um let me go back over here sorry
let's see there's a couple of super
chats that popped in
uh paulus man please say please share
your thoughts on women you are dating
spinning plates while you are also
spinning plates I think it's disgusting
and not sanitary no man in my circle
have an issue with this so I'm seemingly
alone in My Views uh please share your
thoughts on women you are dating
spinning plates
so are you talking about women
dating a bunch of guys I think it's
disgusting and not saying yeah it's
disgusting it's absolutely disgusting
but that's what a lot of women do today
is you know they'll just keep dating a
bunch of dudes until the best one shows
up or until she thinks the best one
shows up and she hopes that she can lock
them down like a woman's sexual strategy
is to try to get the best guy that they
can get that's what hypergamy is
um so that's why you end up with women
that rack up a huge Notch count there's
a video I put out on my uh entrepreneurs
and cars Channel
um the other day if you haven't seen it
it's got title something about like 100
plus men and this woman wrote in
um confused as to why she was having a
hard time finding guys to look past her
promiscuous twenties she's like oh I you
know I only slept with 100 guys and I
was lucky to only get an STD once blah
blah blah it's like guys think that's
disgusting they don't want anything to
do with promiscuous women on a long-term
basis and
statistics prove they are a horrible
option to invite into your life as a
wife so why would you do some stupid
[ __ ] like that
um
so we're talking about peace really
really really really really hard to
attain he says it's the promised land so
he's it appears to be in you know like
an admission of this is really [ __ ]
hard to accomplish
um which I would agree with
he says that you get to peace here it is
through negotiation shocking right the
pathway to peace is untying the knots in
the Rope of your life is what he says
well
good luck with that given the current
environment and if you don't get it
right you're basically putting half your
[ __ ] at risk and 80 of the time uh
you're only going to see your kids every
other weekend if you're lucky
that's how that that's how the cookie
crumbles and I'll get into my stuff in a
minute uh I mean what size can no no he
admits we get tangled up
uh yes
okay and he spent five maybe ten minutes
talking about the differences between
men and women which was a decent segment
I think but where the whole [ __ ]
thing falls apart for me is he offers no
risk mitigation he doesn't deal with any
other any of the realities of what
women want in a long-term relationship
and
you know dude he's like he's the guy
that's all about fix your house before
you try to fix the world right he's like
clean up your room make your bed and
clean up your room get your life in
order but hold on a second
didn't his daughter get divorced
and word on the street was
when he was in Russia
and her husband she was still married at
the time from what I understand was they
are taking care of the kid and the
father in Russia when he was going
through his [ __ ] up [ __ ]
apparently she ran off to Romania and
had a little bit of fun with uh Mr Tate
while married so you know like the whole
fix your house thing first I get it dude
like it makes sense but
have you taken a look at
what your kids have done like I don't
know what the dude has done you know his
his son but Michaela isn't exactly an uh
icon you know to be worshiped for being
honest
based on what I've heard anyway so
of course there's people are going to
deny that didn't happen that didn't
happen Okay well
that's not the word on the street hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out